well this is exciting I'm just trying to
see if this is working
I wish it would be to have everything in
the store I wish for a puppy
I want a better job my wish is I want to
be successful because my uncle Corey
says I have very expensive taste and I
won't be able to live unless it makes
them successful I treadable for when I'm
sleeping
acceptance
one another
I wish
digital pneumatic for life my name is EJ
and my wish is that the Pittsburgh
Steelers could deep enough to beat a
crappy team like the open Raiders world
peace I wish for 37 million dollars
I was for peace
I'd like a watch I said watch that holds
up to my active lifestyle
I wish for the world to
judge people by how they act about my
what they what they've heard about the
land oh yeah I wish for PS3
I like to wish peace peace joy happiness
for everybody that's how it is that was
terrible but it's true what was I
supposed to look for actually you know
what I really want I want to Ducati
I would like the diarrhea to stop
30 years
that's where I want to be